craig stanhope would you guys ever take
wmbd
you might be on the road this is the
number one question i get at comedy
shows when i do q and a on the road i
mean [ __ ] man we could do uh
we could figure something out yeah we
could i'm down it's just you're on the
road i'm on the road we're trying to
make money we're trying to do what we're
doing
but if we did it like once or twice no
i'd be down for that we could try one in
like philly or something something not
too far yeah you know
your brother's car sally head out there
make a night of it
all right all right [ __ ] marry kill i'm
gonna go this is weird cause it's food
but i'll kill french toast i don't need
that well mary i think just means it's
in the rotation i see i'll marry
pancakes and [ __ ] a waffle
yeah i think i'm going the same way i
love i do french toast is classic but
there's something about
you can't pancakes are the most
versatile i agree you got blueberries
you've got you've got points blueberry's
my favorite love banana pancakes you got
chocolate chips
you could do crazy [ __ ] with pancakes
yeah uh yeah so i think pancake is the
no-brainer waffles are great too though
because you do the fried chicken waffle
combo but you can't live off that diet
that's crazy
love why yeah i'm going the same as you
mark i'm copying you there's nothing
like a short stack with the little
butter on top and the syrup falling down
the sides i mean look i love a waffle
but yeah that pancake when you slice in
and they get the it's almost like a cake
you know but i can't do it for breakfast
it's it's a it's the end of the night
thing for me i can't oh we we split a
waffle every time every time really you
feel less guilty if you're splitting it
veter does it sometimes to order it yeah
but i couldn't get one alone i'd hate
myself love a blue waffle